the topic we've been in last few lessons
has been all that these quadratic
equations expressions all that kind of
thing and there's a lot to know about
quadratic equations and solving them
which is why we devote a lot of time to
it but another reason why we look at
this and go into detail with this is
because quadratic equations happen to
come up a whole lot in problems just
arise in the real world in the world
around us so what I'm going to walk you
through is what it means to take a
problem and solve it when the quadratic
equation doesn't leave out there then
you've actually got to produce the
quadratic yourself and use that as your
technique so I have kind of this
skeleton here five steps that you don't
have to follow every single time
different problems will require you in
adapt this a little bit but this kind of
is a pretty decent overall strategy so
let me walk you through it to begin with
you'll get given a situation let's have
a look at this first one here there's a
garden okay and yeah whatever my battery
if it's in a rectangular shape and they
tell you a few things about it the first
thing is we want to describe the
measurements in this question in
algebraic terms that's why we deal with
pronumerals when you've got numbers you
don't know what they are you can still
work with them so you may be required to
introduce a pruning rule like an X or T
or an S or depends on what the question
says if you have a look at this one they
have used X they've provided that to you
or the diagrams so in the easier
questions they scaffold this for you
they kind of say what here take these
pronumerals just run with the ones we've
already given you
other times you're gonna have to
introduce them yourselves secondly this
is the phrase that I want you to have
written down model the situation but
what it means is like what does it look
like in your book it means write an
equation so you might want to put that
in brackets I have a friend and he is a
civil engineer does anyone know what
civil engineers focus on
so civil engineers are about buildings
right so aeronautical engineers about
planes you know
mechanical engineers about engines and
all that kind of thing
civil engineers they make buildings okay
now my friend he's actually a maritime
civil engineer so in the city as we know
where we live in a port right Sydney is
a port and so there's all kinds of
buildings that actually are very close
to the wall or in contact with the water
now when you're out near the ocean
you've got wind's coming through which
actually affect your buildings right
they can't you can't just put a building
wherever you like or make it whatever
shape you like if you don't take into
account the air that's flowing through
you can make a building that actually
has severe construction problems like it
might fall over or whever so as a result
my friend the engineer has a model
there's actually a scale like
construction it looks like a big Lego
set basically that's Cindy every
building every little bit of our copy
down to a tee and they actually blow air
through it to simulate what the air will
do because actually very difficult to
actually create so what's the idea here
our model is like a pretend version of
reality right so it's not the real thing
like you can actually walk into it's
about the size of this room the entire
city of cities so it's obviously much
much smaller so it's pretend but because
of that reason that's why we can do
things to it that you can't do in the
real world so the model that we use is
an equation it's a pretend
representation of this garden and the
numbers in the way they interact so
that's why we're going to write an
equation in a minute
after you've got your equation you can
solve that thing and we have one two
three ways three techniques for solving
them that sort of progressively get more
difficult does anyone remember what's
the first and easiest strategy you
should go for you should try to
factorize that's the first thing you
should try when you have a look at your
equation see if that pair of numbers
jumps out to you quickly often it will
if we give you craft nice and easy
numbers to work with
sometimes you will already be factorized
which is nice but sometimes you will not
be able to think of that parent under so
what could you do next you can complete
the square
completing the square often is required
because sometimes the numbers the pair
of numbers aren't ones that you ever
guess right they'll have SERDES in the
back kind of thing you're never gonna
like come up with that from scratch
lastly you can use what we developed
last week which is the quadratic formula
if you can't factorize either completely
square a credit drag the formula are
both pretty equivalent okay all right
now at the end of that after you've used
one of these three you'll get an answer
right you might say get x equals
negative three or five now this step is
really really important step forth
because usually when we saw a quadratic
equation you get your numbers at the end
negative 3 5 and you finished you move
on ok but if you're solving a real
problem this is something in reality you
have to check what these numbers mean
for instance have a look over here I'm
not suggesting these the answers but if
you got x equals negative 3 on here what
does that mean
have a look at the diagram it might not
mean I'm wrong in fact there might be
there might be what you get at the
quadratic equation what might be the
problem
ok so X here is R is the height of this
rectangle just garden or whatever it is
and x equals negative 3 isn't wrong it
just doesn't have a meaning full meaning
it doesn't make sense in this situation
ok so I've got an answer but one of them
is not valid or maybe both of them
aren't valid ok so you have to check
what this thing means and have a look to
say does this make sense in this
situation the last thing is place
actually answer the question so for
instance here it says the area that
garden is such-and-such and then it says
find the dimensions okay so the
dimensions would be one of the height
and width of this rectangle but I could
just as easily you said well what would
the perimeter of the garden bait
what would the perimeter of the garden
bait now
let's uh let's imagine here right if you
got x equals negative three and fun
you're gonna say okay negative three is
it a solution okay so I think X equals 5
is a solution but you haven't answered
the question you have not sent the
question if you wanted to find the
perimeter what would you do with that
number in this situation okay I'm going
to substitute I'm gonna get a 5 here and
I'm going to get a look look I get 9
there but I still not answer the
question what do I do with those numbers
to get the perimeter yeah I'm gonna get
5 and 5 and then I'm gonna get 9 and 9
sounds to me like the ants will be 28
does that make sense so I might say you
know after going through that I would
say therefore the perimeter is and then
I would actually provide my Artsakh okay
so this number here would you get at the
end may or may not actually answer the
question so go back to the questions
look at the words and then see if you've
got an appropriate solution